um hi everyone to my talk about
performance tricks that I learned from
contributing to open source projects
primarily the Azure service bus SDK so
I'm the kind of guy that I consider
myself a practical learner and I've
invented that term I don't know I do not
know if it exists but I basically when I
read the book about something like
performance optimizations architecture
design whatever I'm sitting in front of
the book and I think like I have it
figured out right and then I'm sitting
in front of my code I'm sitting in front
of my challenge then I'm like hmm how
did that work again and then I basically
go through a series of learning try and
error attempts in order to like really
really embrace the concepts but then I
think like okay then I have it finally
figured out and I my dream was to get
better in performance optimizations
because I was reading a bunch of blog
articles and stuff like that I was like
how could I learn that so I went out
looking for an open source project that
is well a welcoming contributions and I
found the azure response.net CK and they
started basically sending in some pull
requests trying out some of them have
been accepted some of them have not been
accepted but I started gradually
applying the things that I learned from
reading books and stuff like that to the
Azure service bus SDK and
um now I'm around 80 pull requests and
most of them have been merged so I'm
almost some people have said that you
contributed more than some internal
Microsoft employees I don't know if
that's really true but I mean it's it's
an honor to hear that and in this talk I
basically have summarized some of the
key learning learnings I learned from
these contributions to the Azure service
process SDK so that if you are
interested in performance optimizations
you don't have to go through the same
exercise as I did with a lot of like
tears and sweats and midnight
programming sessions until my internet
switch is off I basically have this hack
because I know that when I'm like deep
into coding and stuff I cannot stop
anymore so I basically set my internet
router to switch off and at midnight
because when I cannot Google or Bing
anymore and the internet is gone I'm
like okay whatever and I go to bed so
that's the the trick that I do
okay a quick introduction so this talk
is not going to be about horizontal or
vertical scaling you can achieve a lot
of like throughput performance things by
horizontally or vertical scale
architectures that's not going to be
about that it's also not going to be
about tools like benchmark.net profilers
and stuff like that because that would
be a whole other talk and so this talk
is really about performance
optimizations that you can do in your
c-sharp.net code I will be showing
examples in csharp.net because that's
the language that I use day to day some
of these things can also be applied to
F-sharp or visual basic.net if you're
using that but the focus will be c-sharp
examples and sometimes people ask me but
why.net why c-sharp why manage language
shouldn't you just be using CRC plus
plus wouldn't that be way more efficient
well I truly believe that the.net
runtime over the time has become a
really really good platform for writing
high performance code and people like
aaronstanard for akka.net proof that the
Microsoft Orleans teams proves it there
are a lot of like also online games like
massive multiplayer online games that
are running on.net so it is truly a
platform that is able to to do a lot of
um great things and at a high scale and
I think C plus plus is less and less
needed to achieve quote the performance
higher scale and one of the good
examples that I find is that the the
seizure the sorry.net runtime team they
actually ported the threat pool that was
sort of have managed land have unmanaged
land deported it into the managed land
it's now entirely written in c-sharp and
it performs really really well in some
cases slightly better but it's at least
on par so that's also a good sign that
when you have a common code base that
uses the same language constructs that's
also a really good thing for maintaining
ability so I really love c-sharp.net and
how it can be used with high performing
code sometimes when I do these types of
optimizations I hear from my colleagues
and Pierce is like wow Daniel isn't that
premature optim organizations
some of these things are really highly
esoteric and I'm like is and they're
asking me questions like is this change
really worth it is the complexity really
worth it and these are really important
questions to to ask and I want to I
don't want you to go home after after
this talk and say hey Daniel showed a
few things some optimizations I'm gonna
apply them everywhere in my codes that
is not my message today right because
some of these optimizations they should
only be applied in in the context where
it actually is necessary to apply them
and in some other context and I'm going
to talk a lot about this context you
should not be applying this type of
optimizations because you would be
wasting your employer's time your
customers time and your own time by
doing that so that's really important to
keep in mind so don't jump to
conclusions apply and apply them
everywhere and some I fell into the
spitfall myself so some of these
performance optimizations they can be
highly addictive because once you get
into like this mode of oh I found
something I saw an allocation whatever
and you start optimizing it in it and
then you go into like loops and Loops
until the internet switches off at
midnight right
um but it's really important that you
ask yourself a few questions like is
this is this code going to be executed
at scale and I'm going to talk a bit
more about that because you don't want
to optimize code that is only executed
once a day right because it doesn't
really matter right so code is executed
at scale when it's more efficient in
resource use it usage execution time
throughput and whatnot then these types
of optimization can make a huge
difference and I have this quote from
David Fowler from a talk that is called
at scale implementation details matters
and he says a scale for an application
can mean the number of uses that will
concurrently connect to the application
at any given time the amount of input to
process or the number of times the data
needs to be processed and for me the
last sentence is the most important one
for us as Engineers it means we have to
know what to ignore and knowing what to
pay close attention to right so really I
usually when I look at the code base I I
assume that the people that have written
the code they were smart right they they
made trade-offs they thought about
different like input parameters and how
this code is X gonna be executed at
scale so we have to essentially discover
the assumptions that people made about
this piece of code and hopefully it's
written down somewhere somewhere
sometimes it's not right and we have to
think about well what is currently
instantiated in this specific uh piece
of code per request as an example how
much memory is going to be used and
sometimes people are also thinking like
well it's only going to be used I don't
know 10 times a second right and then we
forget that and then the system evolves
and solves it's going to be executed
hundred times a thousand times a second
and that doesn't mean those people were
stupid it just means that things have
changed and sometimes we have to go back
and re-evaluate our decision making so
that we can actually
improve the piece that is currently
executed at scale and what I also try to
do in my talks is I want to find like
sort of rules that you can apply
yourself so that you have some things to
memorize from from this talk and I have
these rules that I'm going to talk about
and I'm gonna go more into these rules
um along the way of this talk so the
first one is avoid excessive allocations
to reduce the GC overhead and GC is the
garbage collection overhead that's the
first one and the second one is avoid
unnecessary copying of memory these are
the high level categories that I'm going
to talk about today and if you're now
falling asleep because you're long alone
sugar and you're waiting for your lunch
time that's fine if you keep that from
this talk then you're already good and
if you look into your cool basis and try
to look for these things that's already
good key learning that you can take away
so let's go into the first subcategory
of this avoid excessive allocation to
reduce the GC overhead so the first one
is think at least twice before using
link or unnecessary enumerations on the
hot path so don't get me wrong link is a
great language feature right so I also
love it but it should be applied
um on the specific circumstances and on
the some specific circumstances when the
code is executed the scale link can be
actually a resource Hawk so for example
link is very difficult to be chit
optimized and I know that the.net team
is actually optimizing link more and
more and more and some of the things
that we talked today about link you
might no longer be true maybe in a few
months time or in a year and some things
have already been changed in.net salmon
will be further optimizing.net8 still
you have to pay attention to link that
is executed on the hot path and when I
say cheat I mean the just in time
compiler so let's look first into a
specific piece of code that I have from
the ash service bus SDK we have here the
mqp receiver class and the mqp mqp is a
protocol that essentially allows for
example Azure service bus or event tops
to essentially communicate over TCP IP
with the client application that is
running either in the data center on
premises or wherever it's running and
essentially in mqp there is a and the
special effects service bus there's this
concept of a of a lock token and the mqp
receiver is the driver behind the
connection to Azure service bus and
whenever you receive messages with Azure
service bus the lock tokens represent
the essentially the lock on a message
and when you're done you complete by
essentially giving the service a lock
token and the Azure SDK has these
guidelines whenever they're accepting
essentially innumerable types from the
outside they have to take the broadest
possible enumeration type and that's
iron numerable and here the log tokens
are represented as strings and they're
actually grids so they accept this I
enumerable of string and then what
they're doing is essentially they could
look like this right they did lock token
select new good token then two array and
then they did the lookup with link any
looked into sort of a data structure
whether it has already been seen and
then they went on one code path or on
the other cool path and if we know
what's going on we have to closely look
at the code that is actually essentially
lowered undercover if we decompile it
what we will see is this this piece of
coordinate I know it's a little bit
overwhelming
um I'm going to zoom in a little bit
more so what we see here is we have this
select statement here and we can see
here on this side is this um nine
underscore unscript 2 underscore zero
and then question mark question mark
equals so whenever we see this pattern
sort of simplified we know we're kind of
in a safe Zone we don't really have to
worry about it because it's going to be
a statically cache delegate so that's
going to be fine but if you look even
closer we can see here this new funk of
grid of pool that's essentially points
to these complete internal async method
and that is an allocation that is not
really necessary how can we get rid of
this allocation well we can simply turn
this any statement into a for each Loop
so instead of doing the any we
essentially for each and then we look
into this uh into this thing data
structure that we had there and then if
we find it then we go on one code path
and and if we don't we go then we go on
to the other code path and if we
decompile this code what we can then see
is now we have the pattern that we saw
before let us say this kind of safe
right because now we have this
um C9 underscore unsure two question
mark question mark equals and now we
have a statically cache delegate and we
should be fine are we fine that's an
important question to ask yourself right
because when we're making optimizations
into the code we actually have to
measure whether it actually improved
something and we can do that with tools
like benchmark.net as an example there
are also other tools available that you
can use I find benchmark.net really
accessible to write
um to write benchmarks and I did that
and I actually did The Benchmark and
they compared the before and after
solution against multiple enumeration
types and I know this is a huge graphic
here on the screen I'm going to
summarize it for you so you don't have
to read it all essentially when we get
rid of the link any statement we are
able to do some good performance
Improvement what we see on the first
line we get 20 to 40 percent more
throughput in this piece of code and we
get a garbage collection reduction
chancero garbage collection reduction by
20 to 40 percent that's already quite
amazing right by just getting rid of the
any statement we're actually now able to
pump more and more through participation
code and this is really relevant for
that mqp receiver because we might be
receiving thousands and thousands of
messages from Azure service bus or in
event top it's going to be 20 megabytes
of streams basically per second that is
going to be pumped through the network
channels and we need to then acknowledge
all this log tokens so performance
improvements like that are super
important
but then the question is can we go even
further right and because those who are
not asleep yet they saw that there is
still a link statement in there right
can we also get rid of this link
statement and yes there is I call this
link to collection based refactorings
that you can actually do and the first
rule that I have here is whenever you
have an empty array that you need to
represent use array.empty and the other
one is whenever you have enumericals
that you need to represent that are
empty use enumerable dot NT to represent
those the next one is when you have
collections collections have a pre uh
assigned capacity and that capacity when
you add more items to the collection and
the capacity is kind of about to be
reached the collection is going to
resize itself internally and that
resizing is going to cause allocations
and it's going to use um CPU time so if
you can if you know how many things you
will add to a collection it's usually
good practice to instantiate the
collection with the number of things
that you want to put into then you're
not going through through this growing
and this one is a little bit
counterintuitive the other one because I
hear a lot of teams saying well but I
want to use I read only collection or I
normally everywhere if it's performance
sensitive code it's usually better to
use the concrete collection types
because when you're using the concrete
collection types then there is no boxing
of the enumerator happening and then you
get also less allocations and you get
also far more speed these this rule here
gets more and more optimized also with
things like PTO and the the cheat gets
smarter and smarter over time but still
I still consider it good practice for
high performance code to actually use
the concrete collection types and then
if you if you can for example if you if
you're getting input from the outside
and you need to copy it into a new
collection sometimes you need to get you
need to get the count and instead of
using link count use for example pattern
matching to figure out whether it's an I
read only collection and then you can
have access to the account or you can
use the enumerable try get
non-enumerated account which basically
attempts to find out whether it's
collection type that has a already
account available and then it doesn't
enumerate through the whole collection
that's also a good way to improve
performance and this one is whenever you
are thinking about essentially creating
a new collection type because you need
to copy wait until you really need it
right so basically figure out your
essentially boundary conditions and
whatnot and if your boundary conditions
are reached then exit the method
otherwise once you really know that you
need a collection then create the
collection and this one uh there'll be
dragons uh be careful with this one so
you can essentially try to align axis so
that essentially instead of uh
dot net has bound checks for arrays and
different collection types right and you
can for example write the code in a way
so those bound checks are actually not
emitted anymore that's a way to actually
go into like really performance
sensitive areas you can use unsafe and
one of the things that's also quite nice
you have now these collection
marshalling types and memory Marshall
and unsafe methods available in the.net
runtime that allow you to actually get
access to the underlying sort of memory
of collections but this is really
dangerous so be really careful and think
at least three times before you use
these techniques but it is possible to
squeeze out even more performance so if
you apply this to this piece of code
right because what we had here is we
still had this two array call
um then let's have a look how it looks
like when we when we're doing this so
what the azure.net team has they have a
lot of telemetry how people are using
the SDK and what we can we're able to
basically use this knowledge and we know
that in the maturity of the cases people
are actually passing already
materialized collections into it and not
lazy enumerated uh collections so what
we did is we we said okay we're going to
optimize this code by and we we didn't
have a numeral try get enumerated count
available because we we target net
standard there so we're using a pattern
match to essentially look is this called
this I normally that we're getting from
the outside is it an I read only
collection of string and if it is then
we just pass it to the method if it
isn't we're probably in the case of a
lazy enumerated enumerable and then
we're calling two array and then we pass
this I read only call actually to string
to this method and you might be thinking
but Daniel I'm awake I paid attention to
your rules and you said use the concrete
collection types and now you cheeky
bastard you passing in I read the only
collection of string you are you
tricking me well the thing is with all
these types of optimizations you have to
make trade-offs right and this one the
trade-off was we couldn't just go and
break essentially the public method and
we couldn't violate the rules of the SDK
so we had to make trade-offs and the
trade of us we were going to use the
iRead only collection of string here and
then what we do is we do essentially
figure out the boundary conditions and
if it's an empty array represented as an
array empty and otherwise we allocate
the array and then we just go
essentially and fill the grids into this
array
okay let's have a look how we are doing
now with this optimized piece of code
let's do some benchmarking and this
isn't before and before and after
comparison of the already optimized
version that got rid of the link any
statement to the collection based
refactored version of this piece of code
and if we look we can actually squeeze
out another 5 to 64 throughput
Improvement on the previous already
optimized version and we get another 23
to 61 garbage collection reduction which
is pretty neat right and now we could
say okay let's switch off the internet
and go to bed but if we look really
closely
then we can actually see it and in some
scenarios we're actually doing worse
we're doing 56 worse so we're actually
slower than the previous version that
was far less complex now the question is
should we not do such an optimization
and by the way sorry I forgot to mention
we are worse in the in the in the cases
when we get lazy enumerated enumerables
because then we have to materialize The
Collection then we're actually worse
again the question is should we not do
this type of of refacting and here it is
the answer is it depends right in the
specific code we knew that the majority
of the time in the production cases
because of telemetry and and whatnot we
knew that it's going to be materialized
collection collection so it's a good
refactoring to do and only in unit
testing cases people might actually pass
lazy enumerated enumerables and and then
we can actually go to say okay we're
never in the sort of the danger zone
really for for
um production scenarios where we are
actually worse and then we can make this
trade-off for you for your teams it
might be well we are fairly familiar
with linky we're happy to make the
trade-off to actually get rid of the
link any in this specific example right
but for everything else we just leave
what is currently in place because this
code is going to be it's going to be
fine like that so and then Focus your
attention to other pieces in your code
base where you can probably make even
more
significant improvements than actually
trying to refactor everything because as
we have seen there is a complexity
explosion right we went from a few lines
of code to essentially 20 lines of code
right and these 20 lines of code they
come with a maintenance overhead with a
cognitive overhead whenever you're
looking at this piece of code so these
factors need also be taken into account
and with all the things in software it's
kind of the trade-offs are important and
thinking about these sort of edge cases
and sometimes it means we have to stop
here and we use the first simplify
simplified optimized version
we already touched a little bit on the
closure allocations and I'm gonna
reiterate a little bit on this one the
next rule is be aware of closure allo
allocations and closure allocations they
can occur whenever you have action or
function delegates or any type of
delegates they're accessing State
outside of the Lambda or outside of the
curlies and it's like what does that
even mean okay I'm going to give you an
example so here we have this run
operation method out of the Azure
service bus SDK and this is essentially
sort of a poly retry capability
mechanism and what it does is whenever
they're calling sort of a server method
what they're doing they're they're
wrapping this this method in this run
operation method and the Run operation
method returns a task because these are
going to be i o bound methods i o bound
means we're going to call over nqp TCP
IP or HTTP we're going to call to the
service that is running in the cloud
right and then we have this funk time
span of tasks that's the actual
operation that we're going to execute
that is going to be passed into this
method and then what we're doing is we
have sort of a while loop and we
essentially call this method and if it
was successful return and if if we got
the server busy exception sort of back
pressure from the service then we are
going to retry with task delays and
whatnot that really simplified sort of
poly mechanism that you might be already
familiar with with that is built into
the SDK and if we look at the usage what
we can see here this is such a user
usage with the retry policy that run
operation and if we zoom in what we can
see here there is this online message
patch that's a local variable and then
we see the curly braces around here and
within that within those currently
braces we access this local variable and
then we call create message patch
internal and that is a closure right
because we have something that is
outside of the curly braces that we try
to reach out and then we get a closure
allocation how does a closure allocation
look like again we have to decompile the
code and look at what's actually
happening on the recovers and this is
the gibberish code that gets generated
by the compiler when this code is
lowered and what we can see here we have
this display class 16 allocation and we
have this funk of time span of task
allocation that happens every time we
call this method these are two
allocations that are totally unnecessary
how can we get rid of those so we have
to do a little bit of mental gymnastics
and build sort of a library
infrastructure tool or method um that we
are going to use so what we're doing is
and at that time we were essentially
moving from tasks to Valley task Valley
task is basically a discriminated Union
out of uh of a result that is available
or an i o bound operation that is going
to be executed some people might be
saying well we should be using value
tasks everywhere these days I mostly use
value tasks when I have cases where it's
like a eight or nine out of 10 times I
already have to match your last results
and only in a few cases I'm actually
fetching out to higher Bond operations
your mileage may vary and there are
different ways to approach this I use
this simple rule here that I just talked
about we had well we had already methods
that returned value tasks so our
infrastructure tool also needs to return
a value task and then what we do is we
accept T1 which is the state and that is
going to be passed into this method and
we return a result because we have
methods that return a result right
that's what we're doing then we're
changing the function delegate to accept
T1 and we add cancellation token and
whatnot and we return a value task and
then we pass on line three we pass in
the state into this method why is it
generic well you can't use objects right
because if you're passing in int then
you're going to be essentially a boxing
the int to object and then you get
unnecessary allocations that's why
that's why we use here a generic
and then what we're going to do is we
just pass the state that we got from the
outside into this operation method with
the cancellation token the timeout and
everything and that's basically the
basic infrastructure thing that we have
to have in place and once we have that
we can build sort of additional methods
on top of this library right we can now
represent methods that do not return
anything because we have sort of this
library that allows us to pass in method
that returns something and what we can
do then is
um we when we do not return anything we
return valid tasks instead of valid task
of T resolve we still need to accept
state because we need to make sure that
the state is always within the Lambda
itself and I'm going to talk a little
bit more about this then we have the
function delegate that returns a value
task accesses the state and we pass in
the state from the outside and now we
can leverage C sharp 9 has this Nifty
feature that in the language that is
called Static Lambda so we can
essentially call The Run operation
method and we pass in the Lambda and we
attribute it with static async and
what's going to happen is now the
compiler ensures that within the curly
braces that we have essentially on line
seven and line 11 we can only access
state that is already available within
that Lambda so it's compiler in force
right and what we then do is on line 12
we pass in this state and the operation
so we basically package the state and
the function into a value Tuple and then
we pass that as state essentially into
the function right and then what we can
do is on line eight we can essentially
then deconstruct that state which
represents the state from the outside
plus the operation and then on line 9 we
then call essentially the operation
passing the state timeout cancellation
token and everything and now we have no
access to state that is outside of the
curly braces and now we have no closure
allocations anymore in this piece of
code
Okay then if we decompile it we can now
see that we get the code that we wanted
to achieve by having this static caching
thing in place right we have again our
already kind of familiar pattern that I
talked about at the beginning with nine
underscore underscore 16 right question
mark question mark equals and now we
have a statically cached delegate and we
have we just got rid of two um Allo
allocations
and the thing is how can you actually
discover these types of allocations in
in your code well there is one way you
can do it you can fire up a profiler and
you can look for a sort of a display
class or various action or function
delegate allocations and then you will
see them lightening up and you can go
into the piece of code and then refactor
them out or a more proactive way of
doing it you can use tools like hip
allocation viewer in Rider or the HIPAA
location analyzer in visual studio and
that will proactively tell you when
you're writing the code that you have a
closure allocation and then if it
matters if the code is executed at scale
you can avoid it by using the tricks I
just showed you and you might be
thinking yeah but I don't have fancy
code like that I don't even gonna I'm
not even gonna bother right but a very
good example is that you might stumble
over as well as concurrent dictionary
right concurrent dictionary has methods
like get or ads or add or update and
they accept lambdas and they actually
added in the net runtime they added a
sort of state-based overloads that pass
in a T1 and then you can apply the same
trick because if you have code like that
you also have closure allocations and if
your concurrent dictionary access
happens on the hot path where it's
executed hundreds of thousands of times
seconds you might have a closer
allocations in your in your code as well
that you can with a easy trick you can
get rid of but now you're you're maybe
thinking Hmm but really all this
gymnastic just to get rid of two
allocations why would I even care right
and I brought sort of um something from
from my project so I work for a company
called particular software and we have
sort of a queuing abstraction library in
place that fetches messages from Azure
service bus rapid mq sqs SNS whatever
and it internally it has sort of an
engine we call it the pipeline execution
engine pipeline execution engine is the
piece of code that is going to execute
our customers code like we call it the
handlers and this piece of code needs to
be highly optimized and fast because
we're going to pump thousands and
thousands of messages a second in the
data centers of the customer through
this through this pipeline engine and I
we had closure allocations in there and
I did some optimizations and as you can
see here we actually were able to
increase the throughput of this pipeline
engine by 74 to 78 just by getting rid
of the closure allocations depending on
the pipeline diff and if you want to
know more about the pipe the
optimizations the tricks that applied
there you can go to go.particular.net
ndc-o-slow-23- Pipeline and there is a
blog post where you will also learn more
about the pipeline but as you can see
the allocations are also gone right so
this is by getting rid of all these
allocations we are way way way way
faster so it's five times faster than
before which is uh quite impressive um
and by the way we did even more
optimizations by also applying some of
these uh
um unsafe trickeries that I quickly
hinted at where where there is there be
dragons on the collection side of things
where we essentially avoid the bound
checks and we were able to squeeze out
another 20 of throughput improvement on
on top of what you see here on the
screen uh lately
um good then let's go to the next one
under avoid excessive allocations pull
and reuse buffers and larger objects so
the Azure service bus SDK I already
talked about it has this concept of log
tokens they're basically glorified Goods
right and they're coming from the
network over the aimqp protocol and then
when we when we get it there was this
piece of code in place and um it's I'm
showing it on line one where we have
this array segment and there is this uh
gooit byte array and what it was doing
here it allocated sort of a 16 byte
buffer and then it use buffer block copy
to essentially copy the network segment
into that byte buffer and then it
allocated aguit and so that means
whenever we're getting thousands and
thousands measures of per second we're
essentially allocating 16 bytes every
time for every message right that is a
lot of allocations that are going to
tremendously slow down essentially the
processing of those messages and they're
unnecessary and at that time I was
reading about the thing called array
pool who has heard of the array
poolin.net a few so array pool is sort
of a way that you can get get a raise
out of a pool and return it it's sort of
like a car rental right when you're
going to a car rental you say I need
your three people and you said I need I
need a car that is can fit three people
into the car and the car rental might
give you a four-seater car might give
you a six-seater car depending on the
availability and then you drive around
with your friends right have a good time
in the car and once you're done you
basically clean it or not clean it and
return it to the car rental that's
exactly an array pool right but it just
does that instead of renting cars it
rents you a race
um and that's already available in
the.net framework and I was like I can
use the array pool to optimize this
piece of code and to get rid of this 16
byte allocation so I did that and I'm
not making this up by the way this
really really happened that way so I
introduced this and this I use this
array pool.shared
um and then I rent a 16 byte array and
by the way uh like I said it it you
might get 16 byte but you might get more
it's just that essentially what you're
telling it give me array an array that
can at least fit 16 bytes into it right
that's the conceptual model that you
have to think about and then the rest of
the code is almost the same I rent it
and because I rented it I also need to
be a good citizen I need to return my
car right to the car rental I return my
array and return it back once once I'm
done
and then I was like yes I got rid of
another allocation the team will be
happy and I was like hold on a second
before I am embarrass myself I should
actually know whether this actually
solved something I wrote The Benchmark
right and then I looked at this and
compared the buffer and block copy
version versus the buffer pool version
and as you can see uh said trombone I
got rid of all the allocations so I was
like yes but then I looked at the other
number and was like okay 20
226 times slower than the original
version and now the question is
is this a bad optimization well I would
say it depends right you could say if
you are in a memory constrained
environment where memory is really
important this is an optimization you
can use to say I'm basically trading off
throughput for memory right and you
could use this technique to actually
save allocations even though the code is
slower but actually you can actually do
better right and that's going to be the
next rule for smaller local buffers
consider using the stack
and what we have here is with the
introduction of c-sharp 7.3 there is was
also this stack alloc keyword in spans
what you can do is you can stack
allocate 16 bytes on essentially the
stack of the current method and what's
pretty cool is the garbage collection is
not really is not really involved
because whenever the method Returns the
memory is just going to be freed up and
that is really fast if you use that and
then you don't interfere with with the
the GC I'm going to talk a little bit
more about the span and read only span
and those types of things a little bit
later but we can use this stacker lock
and then we stack a lock 16 bytes and
then what we can do is we can then copy
essentially the the bytes that we got we
can copy it into that span and then we
can create a new grid
and you might be thinking well but I've
read essentially all the grid
Constructors and I know that there is a
grid Constructor that allows you to pass
in a read-only span why are you even
um copying the memory and do all that
type of stuff
um so essentially because we have net
standard in the Azure Service Plus SDK
those those Constructor overloads that
accept the read-only span they're not
available and and in at the time there
was also some buffer pooling around and
the team figured out we need to copy the
memory over further iterations it
actually turned out it's not necessary
to copy the memory and I'm going to talk
about this whenever you can do not copy
the memory because that's even more
efficient I'm showing this here as a
demonstration and what's also really
important here is this code is not
really safe because grids are
represented in endingness and depending
on the Andean in Indian environment the
the bytes are going to be in little
ending or big Indian and if you're using
a copy 2 this does not take in endiness
into account but for Block copy does
actually take and this ending this into
account so you have to be careful the
actual code that we did right into the
Azure service was SK was way more
complex than what I'm showing here I'm
showing this example sort of a
demonstration that you can stack
allocate and then copy memory into it
because it's conceptually simple but I
want to make sure that you understand
that that I I cheated a little bit here
on this on this slide okay let's have a
look how we're doing now what we can see
is this version is 45 faster than the
original version and all the allocations
are gone so we actually have managed to
optimize the code in really neat ways
cool and another thing that I want to
quickly hint at when you stack a look
you might be going to say oh stack color
cool now I know this keyword I'm going
to use it everywhere you have to be very
careful because one of the things that's
going to happen is if you for example
accept stuff from the outside that is
out out of your control you might get
arbitrary stack allocated memory right
in various sizes and when you cross the
when you allocate more memory then the
method stack has available guess what's
going to happen
things will explode right okay so be
very careful so you have to make sure
that you only stack allocate within safe
boundaries and there are a few
guidelines around in the uh the in the
community so for example a good sort of
boundary is 256 or 512. it's not that
they're still writing some guidelines
they're not entirely finalized but they
want to make sure that you take this
this home that this technique is good
can be applied but has to be applied in
the right context okay
good let's quickly summarize the rules
that we had under avoid excessive
allocations there's I think at least
twice before using link be aware of
closure allocations pool and reuse
buffers for small local buffers consider
using the stack I have three more that I
haven't showed here in the interest of
time be aware of parameter overloads
when you have methods that accept a sort
of parameter arrays unnecessary
allocations where possible and feasible
use value types but pay attention to
unnecessary boxing and I think Aaron is
also going to talk about these types of
things it's today I think tomorrow in
stock so also attend this stock is even
going into more depth than I'm doing
today and another trick to actually save
allocations is move allocations away
from the hot path right that's a really
neat trick so if you have a byte array
and you don't want use pooling you can
you can allocate the byte array
essentially away from the hot path and
if you know you only have a single
thread that is going to be entering that
method you can essentially reuse the
Same by terrain the override from from
time to time with of course making sure
that you only read then what you
actually have written but we're going to
talk about that as well
the last categories avoid unnecessary
copying of memory and I already talked a
little bit about this span and span of T
and read only span of T right that
essentially is conceptually is span is a
pointer to memory location and it can be
any arbitrary memory can be unmanaged
Memory it can be managed memory you have
a pointer and you have a length that
determines how long essentially the
memory is that you want to access and
for me conceptually and this is highly
simplified it's actually more complex
than that but I consider more like a
curtain right you basically have a chunk
of memory and then you point to a
specific location of that memory and
then they say well I have length 16 and
then you basically pull in the curtain
so that you only see the memory that you
want to access so it gives you safe
boundaries around a memory and there is
also the other cousin of span it's
called memory memory of T that's usually
for a heapa allocate stuff again I'm
highly simplifying this there are talks
of available that you can watch there
like they go into an hour of the
difference between span and memory
because in reality it's a bit a little
bit more complex but I want to give you
a sort of a conceptual understanding of
span and and memory and span is
available when you have methods that
return uh T results or void right once
you actually have for example async
stuff with Ace task task of the result
value task you cannot use spans then you
have to essentially if you want use
spent you have to refactor your code
into sort of a synchronous path that
uses the span and into an asynchronous
path then you can only use a memory of t
or read-only memory of T so these are
sort of the the conceptual things that
we have to take into account so I have
two rules here so look for stream and
byte array usages that are copied or
manipulated without using span and
recently David Fowler made a tweet
apparently stream
manipulations to array and stuff like
that are still the highest causes of
allocations in the.net in many.net
projects so look out for those and
replace existing data manipulation
methods with newer span or memory based
overload so over the time the net team
added more and more and more methods
that essentially instead of accepting a
byte array they accept now read-only
span or read-only memory and you should
be using those overloads because then
you can do a few Nifty tricks that I'm
going to talk about so the last example
brings all these things a little bit
together and it's a little bit more
complex it's going to be about event Hub
so the event tops is sort of a streaming
service right where you can for example
pull it push in your iot iot data as an
example your events into eventops and
eventops has sort of a partitioned
partition publisher and the partition
conceptualist is sort of when you for
example you have books in your bookshelf
right and you want and then you want to
basically take out sort the books they
want to say all the books with author a
go into box a and all the books with
author that start with b going to box B
and that is sort of partitioning where
you for example partitioned by by the
author the first letter so the
simplified version of partitioning and
that partition key resolver has a
partition key hashing function
internally and that hashing function
figures out into what partition
essentially an event needs to go when
using the event tops and that hashing
function is used on 30 to 40 percent on
the hot path when customers that are
using this this publisher are publishing
messages to the event tops and because
event tops as a streaming service should
be like be able to ingest like tons and
tons of data right the the CPU that
we're going to use as a as a publisher
is going to significantly impact the
throughput against even eventops so and
that makes a non-trivial amount of CPU
and memory that is going to be spent for
no added value and I have here the
original version
of the generate hash function and that
hash function by the way is the hash
function that is also running behind the
scenes and it has to be kept highly
consistent across all the languages of
the Azure SDK and that's how it looked
like and sometimes copying of memories
not really really obvious you have to
look very closely and what you can see
here this generate hash code function it
takes a partition key right and the
partition key is output that comes from
the outside so someone can put in one
letter right and then the string is
pretty short someone can put in my name
which is because I have swiss German
Roots is already quite long right so
Daniel Marbach so that's going to mean
it's going to allocate
probably in relation to to that string
that I'm inputting so what we can say is
that essentially depending on the input
this method will probably allocate
various amounts of memory how do we know
that well if you look closely we have
this getbytes method and get bytes
already kind of hints at something is
going to happen and bytes will be
returned and because we use the method
and we can see it actually in line 11
that returns a byte array because it
returns a byte array there cannot be any
pooling involved right because the.net
runtime doesn't know what you're going
to do with despite array maybe you
assign it to a static field right or
maybe you're going to call it every time
this method is going to be called here
it's going to be allocated every time
this method is called and it told you 30
to 40 on the hot path right whenever we
publish we're going to essentially
allocate a byte array array that is in
relation to the input that came from the
outside from the partition key and that
is going to be a ton of memory let's
have a look how we can actually optimize
this and here I have the full version
I'm going to zoom in so for for your
better understanding so the first thing
that we do is we want to use this
band-based overloads that I I showed you
in the rule use the span by its overload
so we're going to turn this partition
key that we get from the outside we turn
it in into a span and then we're going
to apply a technique that I I call sort
of over renting and what we're going to
do is we're going to use get Max byte
count so there is a get byte count which
gives you an exact length of the string
but we're not going to use that because
we are not really interested in the
exact length of the string we just want
an approximation that's already quite
faster than essentially having to go
through all the chars in the string to
figure out how long it is
um we can just say hey tell me
approximately how long it is it's a
simple math method that is going to take
the length of this thing multiplied by
four and then we we have that and then
what we're going to do is we're going to
combine the two rules the stack
allocation right for small and local
buffers we use stackalock for bigger
ones we're going to use the array pool
so what we're doing is we Define an
arbitrary stack limit here I I've chosen
256 because it's sort of safe value we
could also have chosen 512 but
definitely something below one megabyte
so and then we're going to say well if
the length is smaller than our stack
limit we're going to stack allocate a
memory on the stack of the maximum stack
limit so I'm over renting right I'm
basically I'm saying hey give me more
and yeah I'm going to further iterate on
this why this is actually faster than
allocating a specific chunk of memory
that has the exact size and then if
you're not in in that sort of Stack
limit we're going to use the array pool
so we're getting essentially memory from
the shared array pool and then what
we're going to do is we're going to use
a method it's also called get bytes but
this time we're essentially giving sort
of the buffer that we allocated the hash
buffer we give it from the outside so
use the span based overload that accepts
that span of charge we pass it in which
is the partition key we pass in the
buffer we're telling hey I'm owning this
memory please use this memory right we
give it to the methods and then the
method which is pretty cool will
essentially fill it in plus it will also
tell us how many bytes it has written
right and now what we can do is we know
we have enough space to actually write
into we are we overrent it and then it
writes into and says we might have 256
right and but it only wrote 16 bytes and
it will tell us hey I wrote 16 bytes and
then what we can do is we can use the
span slicing mechanism which is
basically drawing in the curtain right
and we can tell it hey slice it down to
essentially from zero to what you have
written that's for example in the
specific example 16 bytes and then we
pass that to the compute hash method
method and then what we the compute half
hash method is sort of in the safe zone
of only being able to access the that 16
byte memory in this the previous example
or only in the sliced memory right so
that's important part and then if we
were in the case where we actually got
the shared buffer what we then have to
do is once we're done return the share
buffer and you might be thinking but you
should probably be using try finally
here right because you always need to
return the buffer when you used it well
we looked at the error cases in this
piece piece of code and we concluded we
couldn't come up with an error case
where we would actually need a try
finally so because this is performance
sensitive code we also took into account
that try final will actually add
additional method overhead we'll make
the method bigger so we actually avoid
it to try finally here to increase the
performance even even more
and by the way the documentation on the
array pool also says you don't have to
necessarily always return the memories
that you rented from the pool so that's
an additional trade-off that you can
take into account so what I'm
demonstrating here is when you do these
types of performance optimizations you
also have to essentially build up a
deeper understanding of the tools and
libraries that you are using in order to
really benefit
from from these optimizations
good and then again we pass it to the
compute hash method as a read-only span
and because it's not returning a task we
can actually use read-only span good and
the last thing is I told you I'm
overrenting and what what is pretty cool
is because I only get an approximation
that is faster because it's essentially
all of one instead of O of n with the
get Max byte count I need to overrend
but then I can apply this trick and it's
on line one if you notice on the slides
we have to skip locals in it what we can
do with skip locals in it we can
essentially tell sort of the compiler to
not emit the skip locals
[Music]
operation and Skip locals operation
usually the.net runtime tries to be
saved by default and what it does is
when you ask it for a chunk of memory
it's going to clear the chunk of memory
for you so that you have no garbage in
there right but because
we and that's sorry that takes a number
of CPU Cycles right and because we are
we know that we have are in a very
controlled environment where we know
exactly how much we are going to write
in that byte array it doesn't really
matter when we get 256 bytes and those
256 bytes are basically
because when we fill in 16 bytes we know
that we have written 16 bytes and the 16
bytes that are in there and the rest is
chunk because we're going to slice in
and essentially focus on the specific
memory and we only read that we are in
the safe zone right so we can
essentially avoid this local image by
giving this attribute to the method and
then it's going to be extremely fast
so let's have a look if you were
actually really fast and if we look at
and of course we have to think about
various input sizes and to be able to
compare it and we also want to make sure
that we are actually around a sort of
the 256 boundaries as well right I chose
a few sort of real life examples of
partition key faded into this method and
then we can see that we have now a 38 to
47 percent throughput Improvement and
all the allocations are gone in this in
this method
okay so as a quick recap these are the
rules uh look for streaming byte array
usages that are copied or manipulated
without using spanner memory replace
existing data manipulation methods with
newer span or memory based variants and
I haven't talked about this one but
watch out for immutable read-only data
that is copied when the data is
immutable read-only you shouldn't be
copying it around right because that's
an easy way to essentially gain
throughput cool um if you want to take a
picture sort of as a reference point I
have this gigantic slide with all the
rules that I've shown you today so that
you can take it away I also have a link
to my slides towards the end of the talk
if you're interested and this is the
second part of the rules that I just
talked talked about and let's go to wrap
this thing up so I wanna
I want to talk a little bit about the
caveats that I mentioned at the
beginning so
do not go and try to apply these rules
everywhere like I said at the beginning
so when you have expensive IO bound
things in your code like database calls
Entity framework lazy loading and stuff
like that or database queries that take
hundreds of milliseconds because you
haven't optimized the query or HTTP
client stuff that is slow as hell right
then tweak those expensive IO bound path
first before you even go to think about
optimizing your link code and your array
allocation stuff and and whatnot because
then you're going to have like 10x 100x
improvements by optimizing expensive i o
bound paths right but once you are done
optimizing those those things and your
code is executed at scale then you can
actually combine the rules and the
practices that I've shown here today
with with the already tweaked codepath
and then you can get amazing benefits
out of it and sometimes what I also
talked with Aaron recently about this
I'm a believer that when you have a
piece of code first try to optimize the
existing piece of code until you reach
essentially the boundaries of you can no
longer optimize this piece of code
because while you're doing this exercise
you learn a ton about the assumptions
and all the things that are in place for
this piece of code and that what you
learn will also significantly influence
how you are going to redesign later on
this piece of code when you actually
find out well we have tweaked it but
it's still lightening up it's still
going to be a performance hog we need to
further optimize it you can take all
these key learnings from these
optimizations and fit that into your
ideas how to redesign this code so I I
think this is a hugely valuable exercise
and just to give you sort of a
perspective of all the performance
optimizations that I've contributed to
the Azure Service Plus SDK and here with
the event tops if the partition key
optimization some other optimizations
have I have done they have they went
they're now adding up to eight percent
throughput improvements in terms of
publishing performance eight percent and
up to three to four percent in terms of
receiving improvements with eventops
right so who wouldn't want to have like
an eight percent faster car for free
right because once you up update
essentially the Azure service process
SDK that bumps to the versions that have
these optimizations you get an eight
percent faster car which is pretty
amazing except I'm only allowed to drive
a Kia seat so
what's a difficult conversation with my
wife but but anyway so but what a one of
the drive home is essentially right um
it's really important for us as
Engineers coders whatever you want to
call yourself right that we essentially
pay close attention to the assumptions
of the piece of code figure out whether
it's execute the scale figure out
whether it's worth investing more time
essentially to optimize it and if the
answer is no then leave it as is leave
your beloved linky code in there and all
the allocations because it really
doesn't matter but where it does you can
apply all the tricks that I've showed
you today to the code and make it even
faster cool
um that's it I have here a QR code you
can go to you can scan the QR codes you
can go up to the GitHub repository
um there's github.com
performance tricks Azure SDK
um I wish you a great rest of your day
you can also reach out to me at Daniel
Marbach on Twitter or daniel.marbach
tickle.net I will also be at the
particular booth in the exhibition area
for today if you have any more questions
I also have business cards here if you
want to send me an email and send me
some suggestions how I can make this
talk better or if you have questions
feel free to reach out and I think I can
also take one question right now
two more minutes any questions
no one
oh okay so the question is how much
reusability I guess about these patterns
and stuff like that you can leverage
when you do these types of performance
improvements for me the reason
reusability is essentially the patterns
that I talked here right but the actual
applications of can I use array pooling
should I use stack a lock and these
types of things that's specific
essentially for a piece of uh for a
piece of code but in in terms of the
patterns and the practices there is a
lot of reusability and of course one
reusability is if you have sort of a
shared library right you can actually
put sort of infrastructure code that
solves some of these problems into that
the shared libraries right or if in our
case when you have um something like
answer response right essentially those
optimizations are in the shared library
and then everyone that uses the the
library gets those optimizations for
free so there is reuse potential yeah
cool
thank you very much and have a great
rest of your day